[Music]
tonight I'm Brian Ross investigates
ms-13 strikes again murder
New York City's subway platform crime
used by the President to justify
building a border wall but until we
secure our border they're going to keep
streaming right back in but the dire
warnings are met with skepticism and
mockery
did you know Mexicans are scary and we
need to build a wall to keep them away
[Music]
what's the real story about ms-13 Plus
inside an undercover sting I knew pretty
quickly that this was a ruse a cyber
watchdog group turns the tables on
someone they say was trying to spy on
them I'm totally convinced he was spying
on me plus our shoutout for an
investigation that went viral about the
startling differences between two
louisiana high schools one with bustling
white students the other with mostly
african-american students don't want
their kids going to the same school as
black students because of their quote
moral character and now a federal judge
is demanding to know why from the law
and crime Network studios in New York
City this is Brian Ross investigates
good evening and welcome we begin
tonight with a hard look at the brutal
street gang ms-13 and the outsized role
it is now playing in American politics
being used once again this week by
President Trump as a key reason for a
wall across the southern border for the
president the timing was perfect as
ms-13 struck once again this week on a
New York City subway platform the murder
of a rival gang member in broad daylight
a cell phone video of the entire brazen
incident quickly went viral played again
and again on TV news across the country
just yesterday an ms-13 gang member was
taken into custody for a fatal shooting
on a subway platform in New York City we
are removing these
members by the thousands but until we
secure our border they're going to keep
streaming right back in but even with
the graphic video the president's
warning about ms-13 was met with
widespread criticism and mockery they
had a lot of exciting new ideas for
instance did you know Mexicans are scary
and we need to build a wall to keep them
away about fighting aliens tonight then
Sigourney Weaver it was so the question
tonight why isn't the president being
taken seriously about the ms-13 gaining
as a threat to public safety
does his record of exaggeration and
repeated falsehoods include his claims
about the threat of endless 13 does the
gangs violence really justify a wall
across the border joining us tonight is
Mark Morgan a veteran FBI agent who ran
the border patrol under President Obama
and then was actually fired by President
Trump even so mr. Merkin has supported
the president's call for a wall across
the border mr. Morgan thank you for
being here tonight let me begin by
asking you about the president's claim
that the wall will keep ms-13 gang
members out of the u.s. that's not true
is it
no when I was in the FBI I led an ms-13
gang task force so I don't know about
other areas where people are claiming
the president is using hyperbole or
exaggerating but when he talks about the
ms-13 he's not and I know he's not
because I lived it and I worked it ms-13
is the most violent prolific
transnational gang this country has ever
seen and it is in countless cities
throughout this country and it has its
origin in Central America they make
their way through they illegally enter
the country and again they're in
countless cities in this country it's
not hyperbole Brian fact well that's
true certainly there's a threat from the
gang and they are extremely brutal as
we've seen across the country mr. Trump
said they operate in some twenty states
but the question is is the wall the
answer is that the way to control and
13 it's a pretty darn good start and
again we talked about the wall just make
sure and the president's made is clear
now several time it's a physical barrier
it's steel slab for the border token see
through it it's not like the wall of
time is not found free and here's what
it does again the wall that itself is
not the answer it's a significant part
of that multi-layered approach to
infrastructure technology and personnel
and when you have that multi layer of
strategy and the right areas it
absolutely is effective and what it's
going to do is it's going to take that
Avenue away from them as 13-2 just go
back and forth the borders illegally
it's going to force them to go to the
fort where we are offensive in nature
and we stand a heck of a lot better
chance of interdict in them when I when
I led the ms-13 gang task force we would
catch them on wires Brian and they would
laugh because how easy it was to go back
and forth United State in New York the
individual that the gang members caught
he's come back and forth several times
it's easy for them that that wall is
going to absolutely and freeze the
border trolls ability to interdict them
but mr. Morgan I've talked to a lot of
your former colleagues of the FBI have
been working against ms-13 in the last
two years they say they come in mostly
through the ports of entry they use all
kinds of tricks at the border to get in
what does the wall do about that so
people are saying the same thing about
drug that the ports of entry they're
more drugs are interdicted remember we
have to we have 2000 miles of border
only 654 of them have any type of
physical barrier at all so over a
thousand miles is still wide open the
issue the true issue is we are not
stopping half of what's getting through
so we don't know what's getting through
but I can tell you they're getting
through because the border is so poorest
they're going through the fort and
they're going in between the ports but
you would agree would you it's not just
the wall is gonna make the border more
secure there's a lot of high technology
that's needed Brian absolutely and if
you ask any expert they're gonna tell
you technology is absolutely integral
part of that as well as personnel the
wall by itself
will not solve the problem that's that's
not that it will not you have to have
the wall as part of infrastructure and
technology and personnel mark Morgan
thank you very much for joining us
featuring the work of a cyber watchdog
group at the University of Toronto
called citizen lab the group told us how
they had discovered Saudi Arabia was
apparently using some sophisticated
spyware made by a company in Israel to
track the phones of Saudi dissidents
including Friends of the murdered
journalist Jamal khashoggi then the day
after our report a strange twist what
the New York Times called a case of a
bungling spy who apparently was trying
to trick the Citizen lab into revealing
sensitive information about how they
were here's an inside look with their
video about how it went down the setting
a five-star hotel in New York City the
host a man using the name Michaele amber
supposedly from a French consulting
company the target john scott Railton of
the citizen lab at the university of
toronto a watchdog group which has been
investigating how the Saudi government
and others had been cracking down on
dissidents in the phone call to set up
the luncheon meeting conducted in French
Scott R Elton says he already knew
something wasn't right
the questions were strange he thought
someone was trying to spy on him I knew
pretty quickly that this was a ruse but
Railton decided to show up at the
Peninsula Hotel for the luncheon meeting
anyway and see if he could turn the
tables on the man he thought was trying
to spy on him since I've been working
with reporters from The Associated Press
since December on this case we decide
it's time to move towards a sting and
we're gonna see if we can catch them
red-handed trying to run this operation
and so that you sat down for lunch so we
sit down for lunch scott Railton says
his hosts steered the conversation
toward an Israeli company called NSO
which his group believes was helping the
Saudis to track dissidents so they were
trying to gather information from you
about the work that was left us that's
with a focus on the NSO group that's
right he Israeli companies right Scott R
Elton says he was recording Michelle and
he says he's sure Michelle was recording
him can I see your pen for a second
so usually when you talk to a person you
rarely aim the cap of your pen at them
for extended periods of time I could
tell that the pen that he was using kind
of hole in the top and I felt pretty
certain during that conversation that
there was either a camera lurking in
there or a microphone but Scot Railton
had his own cameras and watched as the
reporter and the photographer from The
Associated Press moved in to confront
this shell well and you know it's very
strange she says it doesn't exist the AP
reporter Rafael Saturn tells the man his
colleagues in Paris could not find the
company he claims to work for yes number
77
[Music]
it strains your company it's not there
we can't really figure it out could you
is why are you that can you get though
we should produce a show can we have a
speaker before he's very unhappy as we
follow him and the AP reporter asks and
some pointed questions about who he
works for
and why his company doesn't seem to
exist finally after making the rounds he
finds an open door towards the back of a
restaurant and scoots in it and that's
the last we saw of Michel so who is
Michele well
Michel according to reporting that came
out yesterday from first Israeli
reporters and then the New York Times is
actually named aha I'm Moog asleep and
he's somebody with a background in as an
officer but he was spying on you you're
convinced I'm totally convinced that he
was spying on me we were put in a
position where we had to take some kind
of special action in this case and I
think you know we did what we had to do
I would hope though that this is read
also as evidence of something bigger for
years our work has been based around
showing that there is a commercial
spyware industry that's out of control
and that industry although it claims
that its products are being sold to
tackle criminality and terrorism which
is undoubtedly true I'm not arguing that
police with proper accountability
shouldn't have the ability and shouldn't
be properly technically empowered to
conduct their work but what concerns me
is an industry that will sell things to
states that have a history of lack of
accountability and bad behavior look
clearly you're doing something somebody
wants to stop I think that's right and
to me that's evidence that we're doing
good and important work and it renews
our motivation to continue our
investigations
a spokesperson for NSO the Israeli
company declined our request for a
company official to appear on our
program today
the spokesperson denied the company NSO
played any role whatsoever in trying to
spy on citizen lab and while all that
was going on with Susan lab Reuters
broke a major story about another case
of alleged spying of journalists in
human rights advocates
Reuters learned that former US
intelligence officials had actually gone
to work for the United Arab Emirates
what at first was supposed to be a
program to detect terrorists seems have
turned into an effort to target
journalists and dissidents using
techniques known to the former American
spy officials here are some of the voice
of the Reuters video posted with their
story an investigation by Reuters found
the group helped the UAE spy on targets
such as rival governments and militants
in an operation codenamed project Raven
it also targeted human rights activists
who were critical of the UAE s monarchy
the UAE s Ministry of Foreign Affairs
and the NSA both declined to comment but
hackers reuters spoke to say project
Raven went even further putting some
Americans under surveillance joining me
now is one of the two waters reporter
who broke this major investigation Jones
Schuckman Joel thank you very much for
being here this is quite a story how'd
you get onto it it's kind of it was kind
of crazy it was like one of those things
okay I think I heard about it from
somebody when I was at a bar and it was
kind of just like one of those tall
tales you hear somebody was telling me
that that he had heard people were like
leaving the United Arab Emirates and
leaving their jobs because they were
worried because they were being asked to
spy on other Americans and it just kind
of sounded like something that was too
crazy to be true and you know it's one
of those things that you would never be
able to report secondhand but very
quickly we were relatively quickly we
were able to actually find the people
that this happened to and you know and
they shared their stories with us and
they had documents to substantiate their
claims and it was something it was one
of those things he kind of like couldn't
make up almost you know you had one of
the former American NSA officials
actually speak to you on the record
Laurie Strode
how did you talk what did she say yeah
so her story her story was incredible
and her story was that she had been a
you know an elite hacker for the NSA in
Hawaii
a targeting foreign governments like
China for you know for the US and you
know she got after a few career setback
she had got this like you know what she
saw as being a great opportunity to work
for a intelligence contractor in Abu
Dhabi and she you know didn't
necessarily ask like that many questions
before she arrived there which is kind
of not that uncommon among intelligence
contractors who often aren't really
fully clued in to what they're gonna be
doing until until they're there on the
job and once she arrived she found out
that the mandate was was quite broad
that she was going to be working
directly for an Emirati spy agency
spying on you know terrorism suspects
but also human rights activists and
journalists and you know anybody who was
kind of like a political dissident who
spoke poorly of this of this monarchy
and you know she was she was pretty okay
with that for a while for several years
and she did really well on the job and
she kind of put aside her kind of qualms
about it but then you know one day she
came upon you know some names on the
list and she's like well these people
actually are described as Americans you
know they're their nationalities
American and they're journalists here
actually spying on American reporters
here and you know that was like too much
for her to swallow I think that she went
on the record in this case because she
felt like this was a story that was
already so complicated and so shrouded
in mystery and she really thought that
you know it required that type of
exposure that type of credibility that
you get from actually having somebody
who can speak with that sort of
authority on it and actually having like
that like a face and a name to it and
you know I think thought it was a you
know a very brave thing for her to do
absolutely Joe we've got about thirty
seconds tell me is the FBI now
investigating this was a law broken yeah
yeah so
the FBI is investigating whether the law
was broken whether indeed you know this
this this project is project Raven
whether they were involved in spying on
Americans and whether the American Intel
were involved in leaking you know
classified information or classified
methodology to foreign intelligence
operatives jealous Schuchman of Reuters
thank you so much great work when we
come back our shoutout for a reporter
who went into the deep south and gave a
voice to high-school students who wanted
to know why they were treated so
differently from the white students at
the high school up the road
and tonight a shout out for a reporter
whose investigation into the white/black
disparity of two high schools in
Louisiana gave voice to the students who
are getting the short end of the
educational stick and got the attention
of the federal judge overseeing the
school district the mold the carpet the
walls itself the classrooms the teachers
everything that you need in the school
or could use in the school is not there
reporter Dan Lieberman the online media
outlet now this went to Catahoula Parish
in Louisiana to block high school where
most of the students are
african-american to see why students are
speaking out in what conditions and deep
south schools are like more than six
decades after desegregation we saw a
local news piece from rural Louisiana
about these kids were protesting
conditions at their high school what
you're doing how you expect me to do
I talked with Lieberman at the now the
studios in New York where the kids
afraid to speak out where they afraid
they might be punished by the school
they were surprised to see that that
someone from out of town out of state
was showing up to really put a spotlight
on these issues they weren't sure it was
going to make much of a difference
because they really felt like in this
parish in this state they're their
voices didn't matter and they weren't
gonna get a change what made the stories
so powerful is what Lieberman then
discovered nearby but 13 miles away
there's another school in the same
school district that looks a lot
different nearly 90 percent of the
senior class here is white they perform
better academically and enroll in
college at a higher rate it really did
feel wrong it felt like an injustice
this is one School District the schools
should not look that different and that
you know that there's been desegregation
orders in place since the 1960s
and for you know
if you're in 11th and 12th grade at one
school majority-white
other school majority-black you look at
the conditions of the two high schools
and and you see that the funding doesn't
add up so we just tried to film inside
Harrisonburg high school but the
superintendent won't let our cameras
inside they don't want the principal's
to talk to us on camera but there's a
clear notable difference in how the
school looks compared to black high
school but Lieberman was able to get the
superintendent on camera when we talked
to students and we talked to families at
black high school they compared it to
Harrisonburg they say Harrisonburg has
beautiful facilities why do you think
they're saying there's such a difference
several of the other schools communities
of past Bondi she's specifically around
facility renovation and refurbishment
and in the recent years Johnsville
hasn't passed any such issue to address
their schools both high schools are in
the same district and Lieberman says he
thinks there's more to it than bond
issues after talking to one school board
member so I asked the school board
member why don't we just consolidate the
schools and she said the parents at that
school they don't want their kids going
to school with those kids because of
their moral character that's what she
said yeah when it was what a big load
for its cause it's a code for racism
it's it and it it was so it was so
obvious you feel it there and it was
wrong Lee Berman's report had immediate
impact federal judge deed Rao overseeing
the long delayed desegregation efforts
in that school district saw the now this
report and ordered a hearing into what's
going on so essentially he was unaware
of this disparity until your report
that's right so he gave you full credit
for bringing this to his attention in
either the school board nor the Justice
Department had done that he said I'm he
said that I'm so glad you came down
Louisiana why do you think it took an
outsider to go down there and
reveal this to me I really think that it
speaks to the broader crisis and
journalism where areas like this in the
deep south in rural areas they're not
getting asked tough questions reporters
are not showing up they're asking tough
questions
but now they will have to answer tough
questions from a federal judge judge
drell at a hearing scheduled for next
month so a shout out to reporter Dan
Lieberman who I'm proud to say began his
professional career working with me as a
young man at the ABC News investigative
unit he's continuing to make everyone so
proud that's our program for this week
thanks for joining us we'll see you
right back here next week
good night